denis est un mordu de la pêche chaque
année en mai il réserve sa fin de
semaine de pêche dans une pourvoirie ce
printemps sa facture s'élève à 1000
dollars il a déjà versé un acompte de
300 da
les deniers le soir un appel de la
pourvoirie son voyage de pêche est à
l'eau ou plutôt sur la glace le lac est
encore jeudi la pourvoirie lui offrent
d'autres dates
mais aucune d'entre elle ne fait son
affaire denis demandent à être
remboursés mais la pourvoirie refuse en
disant qu'elle peut offrir le service à
une autre date
qui a raison un lac gelé à la fin mais
c'était prévisible
on appelle ça une force majeure et selon
le code civil
cette force majeure libère la pourvoirie
de son obligation d'offrir un séjour de
pêche à denis à la date prévue
mais toujours selon le code la même
chose est vraie pour denis viennent
l'obligent à changer les dates de son
voyage il est donc dans son droit de
demander le remboursement de la somme
qu'il a déjà versés
le fin mot de l'histoire une pourvoirie
ne peut pas rester de glace face à ce
genre de réclamation